ladies an interesting City the other day
I was in the alley behind the house and
I saw a dude pull down his pants and
take a [ __ ] mmm that wasn't the
fucked-up part the frontal part was that
he was looking at me like I was doing
something wrong
oh hey what the [ __ ] are you doing I the
[ __ ] you lookin at you never seen nobody
take a [ __ ] before
oh excuse am i doing something wrong am
I the criminal okay that's cool whatever
do you crazy
Oh what is going on you two you don't
have realize that a lot of us run into
nowadays liars
telephone wire that's not it look I'm
not gonna lie everybody now and then
held a white light here and there
because at times it just might be
necessary sometimes we got to do it to
cover our asses and other times we might
have to do it to spare other people's
feelings I don't know but occasionally
there are some stupid [ __ ] that people
lie about that's just I don't know it
don't make sense to me I remember when I
was a kid and if I did something wrong
and I wanted to lie about it my dad told
me that if I just told the truth then I
would not get punished funny [ __ ] that's
or not to be alive just appeared that in
what you do daddy don't get mad okay I
crash the car oh thank you you know but
here you're like that we hear a little
bit too often don't really pisses off
but definitely makes us crack the [ __ ]
up so yeah
it is the dumbest thing when somebody
was better than me goes to a buffet and
says oh how do you walk into a buffet
and actively just eat one plane that'll
make you healthy make you stupid [ __ ]
let me ask you something you know
buffets the porn world right you know
what that means it's French but eat -
you [ __ ] yourself so let me get this
straight
you're gonna go to a hall you keep
restaurant and then tell people that you
want to die who are you fooling so
you're telling me you want put a space
in front of a grizzly bear I'll be like
ah Charlie calories [ __ ] you must be a
lot stronger than me I can't do that
that's the perfect storm I'm broke and I
bet that goes against everything other
than grown-up man if anything if you
ain't doing no trying to get the best
bang for your buck
cheap as hell you will the only people
on earth they'll complain about nasty
boom but still eat the whole goddamn
thing [ __ ] oh my god I am so sorry I'll
return for you busy when they're not you
ain't busy you basic [ __ ] I know what
you do on a regular basis tell about
your schedules Pat damn straight you pet
that with juggling nuts in your mouth
that's why I said what how many times
have you found out that somebody was
conveniently busy the moment you ask
them to do some [ __ ] for youth whack ass
[ __ ]
you know what the next time you say that
you busy what am I gonna do [ __ ] watch
me surprise you at your house catch you
watching Korean make it porn with a
possible yes that's right I some [ __ ]
about you you [ __ ] sick freak I think
that when you tell somebody who is
actually busy that you're too busy to do
[ __ ] it pisses them the [ __ ] off right
so that we all get busy to a certain
extent but we always getting [ __ ] done
and we always follow through one of my
biggest pet peeves
I wish the worst the pump [ __ ] like
you you know what not even regular [ __ ]
at that I love your [ __ ] ass falls into
a fish tank full of great white sharks
with two fish heads chained to your
nipples and a turtle head attached to
your butthole
what why are you always gonna lie about
[ __ ] that you've done listen I don't
care about you I'm not somebody you want
to oppress I'm broke I'm cheap and I
sure as [ __ ] don't put
I'm a treasure [ __ ] all this
right here what if I say [ __ ] like this
for some reason will you be people in LA
everybody loves to talk about the [ __ ]
that they've done in the first two
seconds that you meet them you ever
noticed that every time you run into one
of these guys they always like to outdo
your life story because they run I
should say hey I'm Rob after writer and
philanthropist painter yoga method ninja
turtle catch answer is world hunger I'm
Jesus
this [ __ ] Oh what is going on YouTube
thank you for tuning in to another vlog
you know what a heel if you guys have
suggestions with long topics please
don't be afraid to go ahead and let me
know because I want to be interactive
with y'all I want to do this thing like
here what I'll talk to you when you talk
back your pain yeah so don't be afraid
and you'll notice that a few times in my
vlogs that I do mention that a lot of
people mentioned their comments and I
put it up as a blog topic that's right
you're involved and you guys already
know on Friday and 5 p.m. we released
three more new designs on our spring
line that go for broke apparel and
everybody was hyped about the cherry
blossom tea yes and you could get it in
a crewneck also a tank and of course the
tea
Bay baby but once again thank you guys
who supported me in the apparel line and
also when it comes to YouTube because
you know I love you guys and you know
fashion was always something that me and
Paul want to go into and that's why
we're bringing out these don't best
French design for you and of course on
our first release we also put a fence so
for you guys that's how much we love you
man but yes buddy fit fit we'll be back
on Wednesday and yes I do appreciate you
guys keep on the grind and I love you
guys very much so I will see you all
next time
watch this karate chop if this was a
person knocked into the neck baby dead
like this but your puberty
watch me bust you have watch this wait
what mm-hmm what am i doing what is this
wonder
so you'd live you want to say brother I
should say so they just started but
you're up you like that just say the
linemen you're in a few lies what about
the live dog just be honest you could
talk to me we friends right